so let's just say you're US president
you go to work and you're getting a
report first thing in the morning
whatever time you wake up whether it's
7:00 a.m. you wake up or some president
who wake up at 10:00 a.m. and you get
this reports telling you hey president
sh can you please wake up please please
wake up we got reports that our military
bases have been attacked 78 times the
last couple weeks should we do anything
about it do you just kind of roll over
the other side do you say what did they
do to who to us 78 times that can't be
real let me read it to you here's CBS to
you Iran back mil
in Iraq have claimed responsibility for
dozens of attacks that targeted bases
housing US troops in Iraq and Syria
since Israel declared war on Hamas 2
months ago the US military says attacks
have been carried out against us
facilities over the past few weeks of
which 37 were in Iraq and 41 in Syria
and US has done nothing about it so if
you don't do anything about it what are
they going to say keep attacking they're
not responding they're okay and in all
of a sudden we see video of this
organization houthis and they're coming
in a helicopter and they get on this
ship ship called the Galaxy leader and
you're seeing this hotti militia getting
on there with guns with weapons and then
all of a sudden boom they take ownership
of the ship and then they're dancing at
the end yeah it's a great idea who does
this ship own to it was built in Poland
it's a big ship who owns it it's owned
by Ray shipping so what's Ray shipping
it's a company partly owned by Israeli
businessman Ramy unar okay so they're
attacking an Israeli owned company
taking over the ship why is it such a
big deal because we hear about Hamas we
hear about Hezbollah but who I mean we
have to now worry about htis well htis
is five times the size of Hamas just so
you know they're bigger than Hezbollah
they got a pretty good amount of budget
and why are they targeting these ships
in a Red Sea because that's the way that
goes to Suz canal and by the way 10% of
oil in the world goes through there 12%
of all export goes through there 30% of
containers it's a trillion dollars of
trade that goes through here in the
hooes have put the fear into everybody
else and you know what they're saying
this is the line of what their leader
said yusf al- modani one of their major
generals said any escalation in Gaza is
an escalation in the Red Sea and any Cal
in Gaza is considered a cal in the Red
Sea he continues any country or party
that comes between us and Palestine we
will confront it by the way their allies
North Korea Iran Syria their enemies
Saudi Arabia us and Israel you see
what's going on over here now having
said that not a lot of people are
talking about this but there's a major
consequence cuz a lot of companies are
saying we're just not going through this
here we're going to talk about all of
that
today okay so if you give out yet of
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let me give you
a quick timeline on what's going on so
remember how I talked about the Galaxy
leader that went through what it went
through that was on November 20 when it
was hijacked by heavily armed militias
and hooti operated helicopters then
afterwards December 4th US National
Security adviser Jake Solomon told
reporters that the US is working to
build a coalition with partner Nations
to provide protection for global
Shipping in the region however on
December 16th Destroyer USS Carney
downed a total of 14 drones what is US
officially at War if our Destroyer is
Downing 14 drones our military bases are
being attacked we're not doing nothing
about it how come no one's really
talking a lot about this stuff right now
now some people in the military are
being proactive about this the US Navy
has positioned the aircraft carrier in
the Gulf of Aiden and three extra
destroyers in the Mediterranean the US
Navy deployment extended a third time to
ensure continued coverage off Israel so
look I've been in the financial industry
since 911 the day before 911 and I've
owned stocks bonds mutual funds real
estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my net worth in gold that that I have
access to in case of many different
things that's why we chose to work with
our new sponsor American Harford gold if
you have retirement funds that you
cannot afford to lose American Harford
gold will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Harford gold a precious metal dealer you
can trust they have the finest products
amazing customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
send you and they'll send you up to
$5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so text award value to 65532
or call
866695 7074 or click on a link below so
they're not going to send their ships
through a lot of companies are saying
we're just not going through it right
now it's too chaotic and here's some of
the companies that have made that
decision number one Denmark AP Muller
May on December 15 said it would pause
all Container shipment through the red
SE until further notice following a near
Miss incident involving against vessel
mayis Gibralter a day earlier now MSC
Mediterranean shipping company said on
December 16th it ships would not Transit
through the sus canal with some already
rerouted via the Cape of Good Hope a day
after hou's forces fired two ballistic
missiles at its msse padium 3 vessel the
decision will disrupt sailing schedules
by several days the Switzer base group
said the ship was targeted by missile
while traveling from Salah Omen to Jed
Sai Arabia the company said number three
CAC CGM French company group on December
16th said they are also pausing all
Container shipments through the Red Sea
so is Costco shipping not the Costco
shipping you're thinking about but
China's Costco on December 18th they're
the latest shipping giant to ha Red Sea
route amid the attacks and then we have
a few other ones here we can talk about
we can talk about a German container
hapag ly as well as Evergreen which I'm
sure you've heard about Evergreen before
when they went through their issue now
aside from those shipping companies
here's the oil companies that are say
we're just posing with the biggest one
being BP they're not willing to take the
risk on December 18 they said they have
temporarily paused all transits through
the red SE ecan a Norwegian oil and gas
firm on December 18th said it had
rerouted some vessels that had been
heading towards the Red Sea show has
irav Belgium oil tanker firm set on
December 18 it would do the same so has
front line now for some of you in case
maybe your geography is not your thing
you want to know where these hotis are
they're on the west side of Yemen if you
look at this map look where they are
you'll notice houis are purple that's
their military they're right on the
border of Saudi Arabia and to the west
of them is a Red Sea so any ship that
pretty much wants to go through that
routee you have to go through hotties
they will see you and if they want to
Target you there's a risk that they
can't so what does this means to some of
these guys that are having to reroute
the whole thing all it means is instead
of going straight through the sus canal
and doing the same work in 7200 miles
and less time and less risk you have to
go from Mumbai all the way up to London
it's going to take you 12,300 mi way
more risk way more chappie way more
potential for damage to be taking place
more fuel cost of pricing going up
shipping every everything and that gets
passed down to who the consumer you and
I so there's a lot of elements to this
one of the elements to this I want to
show you some data for you to take a
look at when you're small and you're
going up against the enemy that's
formidable and big the way you annoy
them is by hurt them in a place that
maybe is the only thing you have and in
this situation houes West Red Sea you
want to go through here you need us if
you don't stop the war in Gaza and palan
and leave him alone Israel we're going
to hurt America we're going to hurt
everybody we're going to hurt 10 12% of
the global trade that's going through
here that's what they're doing by the
way if you go through the history of
what happened to the world GDP I want
you to look at two things here here's
what's happened to the world GDP over
the last 5 600 years take a look at this
from 1500 to 2015 notice that sudden
spike in 1950 what does this show this
is us working together and look how that
matches with this other data from growth
of global export look at 1950 it's
really not a big climb from 1900 to 1950
all of a sudden boom Off to the Races so
Global exports equals increasing the
world GDP world GDP increasing more
money for you more salaries people make
more money less stress less chaos the
less money they make the more chaos so
they're trying to cause everybody to
have some kind of pain now here's the
thing I definitely want to see our
military be a little bit stronger in the
way our president could attack to
silence them and put the fears in that
we're not really doing that they have
access to information I don't have maybe
I would take a different approach than
the current Administration is but I'm
not the president I'm creating content
uh however at the same time this could
be a month thing this could be a two
month thing nobody thought Afghanistan
was going to be a two decade thing and
nobody thought Russia Ukraine was going
to be a couple year thing that it's
turned into if this thing ends in the
next week two weeks couple months that's
good if it doesn't you're going to feel
the chaos economically coming to city
near you because this is going to affect
the pockets of somebody and it'll be
passed down to you if you got value out
of this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel if you've never
seen the power of a Canal go watch this
video on Panama Canal you'll realize how
necessary these canals are take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye